so at this point what I want to do is
open a second text buffer a second file
which I'm gonna save as library and the
idea with this is I want a right code
that's gonna make it simpler for me to
write this code later down the line I
want to write some generalized code that
I can consume here in the consumption
case such that when I want to increment
the location of any car object I can use
the code that's written here that's
supposed to be general and useful across
many situations I'm gonna start by
writing a function and I'm going to edit
it so that it's capable of moving a car
input object for us so now by simply
calling that function on our two car
objects we have the same effect as we
had before but without typing out the
incrementation logic each time so now we
don't just have these two car objects
being stored in a me and Ben we have yet
another variable storing yet another
object and this object happens to be a
function object that function object is
what operates on these two simple car
objects and modifies their dot local
property at this point it would be very
reasonable to wonder what we've actually
improved it really seems as though there
is more code in total here than there
was a minute ago and the lines that call
the helper function are just as long as
the ones that they replaced there are
two important differences that I can
think of as to why it's valuable to
factor repeated code like that out into
a function